I want to keep these opening remarks
very brief for two reasons one is that
we're running just slightly behind more
important reason is that I actually
think Larry really needs no introduction
now I had a mentor who said to me I need
no introduction but I always really
appreciate one and so I I definitely
want to say a few words about the
amazing work he's done but Larry really
has become a phenomenon in the short
period of time since I believe April of
this year that the TED talk that he did
on his book Republic lost and campaign
finance reform has been up it's had 691
thousand views now that is a remarkable
measure of the impact but it's it's
actually an impact that in some ways
comes after a career in which Larry has
really has really become had been become
a pioneer in in each of the areas he's
worked in his work on the Internet and
it's and it's and it's architecture
legal and and otherwise his it was
pioneering and very influential and
since he started to work in this area
he's really changed the terms of the
discussion as well as really have
influence not only through his own work
but through the organization that he has
founded and so I will let him talk a bit
about that but what I would like to do
is to is to thank you once again for
coming out and thank Larry for providing
our keynote and I look forward to
continuing the conversation this
afternoon so thank you very much
thank you
it's a pleasure to be here and to offer
a talk which I think has one
controversial idea in it so that's why I
want to call it getting getting clear
getting clear on some things that I
think we should know enough about to be
able to finish the debate that has gone
on for I think too long okay so getting
to that place clear I think it's
important to remember that as important
as that is is how meaning there are
those of us who believe that our
government is corrupt and is corrupt in
a pathologically sense of corrupt but
the important thing is to understand how
its corrupt and how its corrupt is
important if we're going to talk about
what we can do to fix that corruption
okay so how is it corrupt let me start
with that and I think we should
distinguish between a micro perspective
and a macro perspective and the micro
perspective I think is ultimately the
perspective we spend too little time
focusing on so after the last election a
number of freshman congressman do what
freshman congressman do after elections
which is to trundle up to Cambridge to
attend the Kennedy School how to be a
congressman class and after one of those
days about a dozen of these members met
with a bunch of us to talk about
campaign finance and one member started
the meeting by saying I ran for Congress
in my pajamas now he came from
California so I thought maybe this was
just an eclectic sort of candidate
but I said to him well well what exactly
do you mean by that and he said I
literally did nothing except sit in my
house in my pajamas
calling people raising money to fund the
commercials that ran on my campaign
that's all that I did and I said so how
is your life changed since you have been
elected
now I have to wear a suit but it's the
same activity and what I didn't know at
the time but as Huffington Post reported
soon after this conversation all of
these members had received literally
that day a memo from their leadership in
the form of a PowerPoint deck that
included this slide that Huffington Post
released that described for them their
model daily schedule so out of 9 hours 4
hours was to be devoted to call time
raising money and this doesn't even
include what they were supposed to do
after the day ended when many of them
spend their time going around to other
cocktail parties or fundraising events
so the point is they were focusing on
this future life which was not very
different from the life they had just
ended a life that was going to be
spending enormous amount of time raising
money collaborate corroborating a
statistic which I had pulled together
from looking at everything I could find
about estimates of this time that
they're spending anywhere from 30 to 70%
of their time raising money ok now how
should we understand that I think this
is the best image we can have and I
don't have a good video of it but this
is the best image we could have remember
the Skinner box right so the Skinner box
is advice where we take an animal either
a rat or a pigeon I used a pigeon just
to be charitable here and you forced
them to learn the routine they need to
learn in order to raise I'm sorry not
raised to get the food they need to get
to live right and and amazingly these
creatures learn all sorts of dances that
they need to go through to get the food
that they need to give and interesting
psychologically it's best if you don't
give a perfect return it's got to be a
probabilistic return that keeps them
focused so it's the slot-machine theory
of motivation they've got to have a
probabilistic return which keeps them
focused on the behaviors they need to
engage in in order to rate to raise the
money they need to fund their campaigns
and the question we need to focus on is
what does that behavior do to them
what does it do to them which is very
different from the question Ezra raised
today and I just want to pick on Ezra
for a minute here because the question
is not the question of campaign funding
is not does tracking the money help us
beat nate silver on our blog right
that's not why this is an important
problem right the question is does this
money or this way we raise money corrupt
the process of representation for the
people after they've engaged in this
behavior so what does it do
to them and that ant question is
answered by focusing I think on who are
they falling who are they spending their
enormous amount of time calling what
kind of person because if it were random
selection of all of us that would be one
thing but if it's not a random selection
of all of us that's a very different
thing and indeed that's in fact what we
know look from 2010 using centers data
from 2010 a quarter of 1% of people give
$200 or more or gave $200 or more in
2010 to any federal election point zero
five percent gave the maximum amount to
any federal candidate point zero one
percent the 1% of the 1% gave $10,000 or
more in aggregate to federal candidates
in that election and in this election
cycle as demos put it in the interim
statistic point zero zero zero four two
percent and that totals to one hundred
and thirty two Americans gave 60 percent
of the super PAC money that was
contributed right so the point is to
recognize when you have such a tiny
number of people who are the target of
the fundraising activities it can't help
but develop psychologically for all of
these members are kind of sixth-sense a
constant awareness about how what they
do might affect their ability to raise
money they become in the words of the
x-files shapeshifters as they constantly
adjust their views in light of what they
know will help them to raise money not
on issues 1 to 10 the issues that their
constituents maybe notice the most but
it issues 11 to 1000 where the lobbyists
have their most prominent
a fact Leslie Byrne a Democrat from
Jinnah describes that would she went to
Congress she was told by a colleague
quote always lean to the green men to
clarify she went on he was not an
environmentalist so it is this behavior
this experience this way of life this
Skinner box or funders box that I think
needs to be our focus and when you think
about that funders box we have certain
expectations one expectation is that
this will bend policy to their ends to
the ends of the funders and though there
was some obscurity in the political
science literature about this I think we
have to conclude now that that
expectation is supported by the data
there's direct evidence about this it
was originally thrown into some doubt by
my colleagues at Harvard suggestion from
this paper that there is little
relationship between money and
legislator votes but that conclusion was
itself then thrown in doubt first by two
meta analyses that looked at the very
same data which they looked at and
concluded as Straub Minh says the
hypothesis that campaign contributions
have no effect on voting behavior is
rejected at the 1% level and then more
recently Clayton Peoples did a much more
expansive study of 7,000 votes between
91 and 2006 and found statistically
significant contributor influence in
seven of the eight houses the only one
where they didn't was in the house that
passed mccain-feingold which
interestingly if you get them to focus
on ethics legislation they turn out to
behave more ethically interesting
strategy maybe just to have them vote on
one of these things every single
election cycle so that's the direct
evidence and the indirect evidence here
I mean you know marty is right here in
the front so mark Martin's paper which
then turned into a really fantastic book
which looked at it find what Americans
with different income levels different
policy preferences actual policy
outcomes strongly reflect the
Preferences of the most affluent but
bear virtually no relationship to the
Preferences of the poor middle-income
Americans appoints to this vast
discrepancy between what we would expect
and what we find when we track results
as a function of affluence inside the
system
and then this is also supported by Larry
Bartles recent analysis of people at the
very very highest level of wealth way
above what anything that Marty could
look at suggesting how policy tilts to
the wealthy and we can observe the
wealthy because of the point I just made
before are the funders okay so that's
the first point to think about what it
does to them and then we can also think
about what it does to the system because
in an obvious way that we don't
recognize I think clearly enough in any
world where tiniest fraction of the
public is disproportionately driving the
funding for Elections what that means is
that the tiniest number of them really
really a tiny tiny number of them are
gonna have the capacity to block reform
I still haven't found anything other
than a block of cheese for this I'm
looking for Iraq but block reform right
they have the capacity to block reform
because this tiny tiny number is almost
trivial to gather together all around
any major issue that you would have a
desire to affect so we should expect
here that Washington would develop a
kind of economy of no an economy of no
because the simplest good for the
lobbyists to sell is the ability to say
no the ability to block any reform that
might otherwise flow through the system
this is an economy then that depends
upon polarization its economy that
depends upon dysfunction dysfunction
becomes the business model and the leaf
gang had this wonderful little peace in
the nation where he found a website that
was then subsequently taken down by a
lobbying firm that was explicitly
advertising their ability to lock into
senators ability to hold legislation as
one of the things they could sell the
ability to translate that power into the
ability to block change so some in the
room not to pick on Ezzor again but some
of them believe the problem is
polarization but the point is to see how
polarization is the solution to the
problem of fundraising
polarization makes it easier for people
to leverage the opportunity to fundraise
because it makes it easier for them to
reliably deliver the answer of no
against people who are interested for
people who are interested in stopping
the change that might otherwise flow so
I think this conclusion too is supported
it's sort of conventional wisdom but I
think Mann and Ornstein latest book is
really fantastic and bringing this out
describing how we now have a government
more loyal to party than to country and
as a result the political system has
come the grievously hobble of the times
when the country faces unusually serious
challenges and grave threats okay now
all of that I think is from the context
of looking at the micro behavior and
understanding how it's going to affect
the system we should also think about it
from the macro perspective and ask the
question what does the current structure
do for the potential of change deviating
from the status quo and now think about
it from the perspective of the leaders
I'm picking these two as the leaders of
these two political parties and
strategically as a leader of the
political party thinking about the
willingness you have to devote your
political party to a certain political
objective so imagine if you looked at
the pharmaceutical the way we fund drugs
in the United States and you as a leader
of the political party you're asking
yourself the question should we take on
the challenge of radically changing the
way we fund drugs in the United States
you know maybe increasing competition
with pharmaceutical companies or
changing the way the government
reimburses or changing the patent system
so that they can't extract such super
image or super rents for their
innovations when you ask that question
as a leader of political party and you
recognize the fierce competition that
exists between these two parties and how
a tiny shift of money from one side to
the other can devastate your chances you
can see why there would be little little
chance that the political party
leadership is going to adopt a position
contrary in this space especially when
you see the relatively significant
amount of money coming in from this kind
of interest and this in this case pretty
evenly balanced between Democrats and
Republicans
or imagine you think that the way we
produce energy in the United States has
a lot to be desired we have a very
important does not need to internalize
some externalities carbon production and
externalities but you as a leader of
political party have to decide whether
you're going to take this issue up
because to take it up might be to
alienate the significant funding force
which of course the Democrats have lost
in some sense that so far but still
there's significant amount of money they
still get from the people who are eager
not to see this policy issue taken up
same thing on the context of wall street
you know if you think that the way we
have banks in wall street right now
might not be a good idea we ought to
take on this structure and to make
ourselves the enemy of very powerful
interest here you have to face the fact
that this is the largest contributor
largest contributor by sector in our
political system and the Democrats have
already seen the punishment that comes
from even raising your head above the
line here so the Democrats numbers right
now are 8 million versus 19 million in
this is 2012 2008 it was practically
equal so they've already been punished
even for the meager steps that they've
taken but again the point is that you as
a leader of party need to internalize
the fact that you will be punished even
more if you take on this kind of issue
which might suggest why the Democrats
were eager to roll out this Connecticut
congressman former Goldman Sachs
executive a Democrat who is proposing a
bill to deregulate derivatives yes who
can possibly believe this but deregulate
derivatives the meeker regulation
dodd-frank puts on top of them are is
too much goldman sachs says because it's
too complicated of course most people
don't recognize that's very complicated
only because global sachs lawyers
facility has facilitated the process of
making it the most complex regulation
imaginable but this is a pretty eager
way to try to signal to Wall Street even
Democrats can love Wall Street once
again and of course finally and most
tragically for the nation I think if you
think about the decision of a Democratic
leader or a Republican leader to take on
a particular issue in the context of
guns it also focuses on the sense in
which this can be political suicide at
the party level which means that the
structure of competitive races with
massive contributions coming from these
special interests preserve the status
quo locks us in to the status quo with
policy producing again what I think is
this unprecedented lis sclerotic
political structure right so as hemming
once said and the Sun Also Rises it how
did we go bankrupt
the answer is gradually and then
suddenly suddenly now we are bankrupt
from the capacity of this political
system to take on political issues and
address them in a sensible way okay
that's how we are here but let me go
back to the part that still our people
look an equivalent chipped upon this
story when reading an article by Zachary
Bruggeman this is the question of the
framers and the framers designed for the
President and when the framers were
thinking about how to structure the
president they resolved that there would
be an electoral college because national
public elections was not really
imaginable but then the question is what
would happen if there was a tie in the
electoral college who would resolve that
time and it was suggested originally
that the Senate might lose all this time
and his bruckman puts together the
response of that suggestion
he says easy quotes referring the
appointment to the Senate lays a certain
foundation for corruption and
aristocracy noted Williamson from North
Carolina the aristocratic complexion
proceeds from the change in the mode of
appointing the president which makes him
dependent on the Senate George Mason
similarly asserted that this dependence
on the Senate while there were
simultaneous indirect dependencies on
the people would subvert the
Constitution Mason said he would prefer
the government of Prussia to one which
will put under the power of the hands of
seven or eight men and fix an
aristocracy worse than absolute monarchy
and James Wilson agreed because of his
quote dependence
then the Senate the president will not
be the man of the people he ought to be
he would be a minion of the Senate the
dependent relationship posed a dangerous
tendency to aristocracy and if you think
of that language what's odd in that
language is the way the word corruption
is used
I think it's intuitively clear to us how
there's a tendency to aristocracy at
least if you imagine the Senate filled
with rich people which when seventy
percent of the Senate is made of
millionaires the way it is today isn't
such a crazy idea to imagine but wherein
is the corruption the corruption in
having the Senate choose the president
on the happening of a tie in the
electoral college something that's
happened twice in our history and the
reason why this is odd for us is that we
have a very modern sense of the word
corruption and the framers had a
different sense of the term corruption
as Lisa Hill describes it until the end
of the 18th century corruption had a
much broader meaning than it does today
it referred less to the actions of
individuals and more to the general
moral health of the body politic so what
that means is that they could predicate
corruption not just of individuals but
it would predicate of institutions too
so in predicate of the presidency you
would predicate of a society of and
predicate of Parliament it would
predicate of whole bodies and it would
predicate of em meaning that it was
proper to call them corrupt if certain
conditions obtained but that means we
can distinguish between the corruption
of the institution and the corruption of
individuals within the institution so
you can have a corrupt institution and
that doesn't mean that any of the
individuals within the institution are
necessarily corrupt they could all be
angels but still the way the institution
is created the dependencies that exist
with it produce the corruption of the
institution and you could have corrupt
individuals but no corrupt institution
you'd have just have criminals but
within an institution is perfectly legal
and not corrupt so the point is the
necessary and sufficient conditions for
each kind of corruption are distinct
okay now the suggestion of this two
kinds of corruption is inconsistent with
how the Supreme Court
speaks right now Supreme Court speaks as
if the only kind of corruption that's
relevant is individual corruption
corruption of individuals quid pro quo
corruption it doesn't even suggest or
contemplate the idea of a way of talking
about corruption that predicates of the
institution and one thing to kind of
stick in their eye when they talk that
way is to note that only a non
originalist could possibly think that
the only relevant corruption is a
corruption applies to the level of the
individual because for the framers of
the constitution corruption existed
whenever there was an improper
dependence of an institution upon an
influence that was not to be with an
institution that was the point about the
president the mere possibility that the
president would be chosen by the Senate
was enough for them to say the
presidency would be corrupted not
because they expected the Senators to
buy off the president of the President
to buy off the senators but because the
dependence upon the Senate produced the
wrong influence in the president that
was a corruption of the President and
for our Congress the framers certainly
would have recognized the way in which
we've allowed an improper dependence to
evolve inside the institution of
Congress they hadn't intended dependence
for this institution as Madison put in
Federalist fifty-two it was to be an
institution dependent upon the people
alone but the actual dependence that's
been produced as a dependence that's not
dependence upon the people alone but
increasingly dependence also upon a
funders so this is a dependence
democracy then that has its appendage
upon two groups the funders and the
people competing dependencies and
conflicting dependencies because the
people are not the funders people are
not the funders meeting we don't have a
system where the government is dependent
upon the people alone this is
technically and precisely corruption
from the originalist view okay now why
is that important if this were a room of
lawyers it would be much more
significance why this was important it's
because the only place the Supreme Court
has allowed First Amendment values to be
restricted is if Congress can say we are
restricting these for the purpose of
addressing corruption and so if you
think of corruption as only about
individuals then that creates lots of
restrictions on the ability of Congress
to address this kind of corruption but
if you could get the court to recognize
that at least the framers would have
thought of corruption of the institution
it broadens the range of plausible
legitimate regulations that Congress
might adopt so I think the originals
view is true and it's also essential for
dealing with some of the most important
campaign finance cases that are just
over the horizon one that was already
mentioned this morning the McCutcheon
case for example so the McCutcheon case
addresses the question of do the
aggregate limits on contributions
violates the First Amendment because
you're stopping somebody from spending
five million dollars in contributions
right and it's not hard to see how this
could be happening imagine somebody
wanted to give a thousand dollars to
every every every Democrat in every
House seat okay so a thousand dollars
times 435 is way more than the maximum
amount you are allowed to give in
federal elections so that it clearly
exceeds the aggregate amount but from a
quid pro quo perspective this is
obviously below the amount the Supreme
Court believes for each of these races
that could constitute quid pro quo
corruption so if the only kind of
corruption you can appeal to is quid pro
quo corruption you have no way to show
why the aggregate limits are
constitutional limits on a person's
ability to participate it's not quid pro
quo corruption but it plainly and
obviously exacerbates the kind of
dependence corruption that I'm talking
about because the one thing we know from
the data and especially in Montana they
did a great job in putting his data
together is that when you remove the
limits on contributions you shrink the
number of contributors so the business
model of fundraising shifts away from
talking to lots of people to shifting
towards talking to as few a number as
you can which means if we
the aggregate contribution limits what
we'd expect is an even smaller number of
people would be contributing to
campaigns so that if the small number is
what's constituting the dependence
corruption dependent upon this tiny
fraction as opposed to dependent upon
the people alone then we're only
increasing corruption by removing these
limits so this gives you a way to argue
for those limits which is different from
quid pro quo corruption and I also think
it's the key to thinking about how to
address the issue raised in speech now
this was the case decided by the DC
Circuit the Supreme Court didn't review
the case which which created the
opportunity for super PACs so we heard a
little bit of this today from from
senator Murphy but I think it really was
quite compelling Lee described in a
panel exchange that I was participating
him with evan bayh evan bayh was asked
by john samples of Cato sample said well
you know we have no good data to suggest
that money buys results in elections do
we and you know in citing the kind of on
syllabary
research and and by kind of rolls his
eyes and he says you have no idea how
Citizens United has changed Capitol Hill
he said before citizens united the
incumbents were the Barons the
incumbents had absolute confidence as
long as they didn't sleep with an intern
they could be reelected but after
citizens united every single incumbent
is terrified that 30 days before the
election some super back is going to
come in and drop a million dollars on
the other side okay so that fear
produces a sensible response in the
Senators so what did they do in response
well they have to buy this is my word
but you get the sense a kind of super
PAC insurance so a super PAC insurance
is an insurance policy that basically
guarantees that a million dollars gets
dropped against you so we don't come in
and drop a million dollars on your side
to balance it out but you need to
guarantee somebody will be there to have
your back if in fact you need to be
defended and how do we buy insurance
well of course you have to pay your
premium in advance long before the time
you actually need the money
you have to have established the
relationship sufficient to give somebody
a reason to step in and back you up so
how do you pay your premium Vance no
well senator we'd like to help you we
only can support people who support us
at 80 percent you have a target of a way
you need to behave in advance in order
to guarantee that the super PAC will be
there if in fact you need the super PAC
to be there Mann and Ornstein described
a similar story as they say is one
senator told us we have all had
experiences like the following a
lobbyist your interest representative
will be in my office he will he or she
will say you know Americans for a better
America really really want this
amendment passed and they have more
money than god I don't know what they'll
do with their money if they don't get
what they want but they are capable of
spending a fortune to make anybody who
disappoints them regretted no money has
to be spent Mann and Ornstein say in
order to get there that their desired
outcome so the point is this didn't
dynamic also manifests what I want to
call dependence corruption because you
see the members beginning to align their
behavior in light of their dependence
upon these super PAC behaving in a
particular way and because they're
aligning their behavior in order to get
the super PAC to behave in a certain way
they are revealing the kind of
dependence they have again a dependence
on the tiniest fraction of interest
inside the election and as Murphy said
this morning it is developing a culture
of dependency the super PACs are this
dependency which is again inconsistent
with the dependence upon the people
alone in this sense it is in this sense
that I say that Congress is corrupt it
is corrupt in this dependence corruption
sense of corrupt even if it's not
corrupt and I'm happy to stipulate it's
not corrupt in a quid pro quo sense of
corruption okay so how do you do what do
you do about this how do you fix it well
if you focus on the problem as
dependency corruption I think the
analytics to fixing it are pretty clear
the problem is constituted by number
spending way too much time fundraising
from two tiniest slice of America the
solution to this problem is to reduce
the time their fundraising but even if
you don't reduce the time that their
fundraising at least spread out the
people from whom they are raising the
money so if they're raising four
random selection of all of us I'd be
okay if they spend 70% of their time
talking to a random selection of all of
us that would force a kind of reflection
in their behavior that's reinforcing of
the democracy the problem is it's the
point zero five percent they're raising
the money from so spread out the funder
influence to get to the ideal we can
imagine of dependence among the people
alone and to do this I don't think you
need to amend the Constitution I think
to do this this is I think Michaels
point that he's making us more things
absolutely right all you need is a
single statute that would change the way
we fund elections to move us from the
big dollar funded elections to small
dollar funded elections and at the
federal level there are plenty of
wonderful suggestions precisely of
precisely how to do this right now the
fair elections now Act which in 2010 in
the house came within twenty votes of
passing creates a matching fund system
that would do this the American
anti-corruption Act has it has what's
described right now as a tax credit to
do this this this bill of course is the
most ambitious reform proposal we've
seen in a hundred years in America but
the funding proposal is basically
functioning as a tack credit proposal
right now in my book I talk about a
voucher proposal of building on Ian
Ayres and Bruce Ackerman's idea to
voluntarily have people opting into
taking small vouchers only and then
fundraising to raise those vouchers plus
contributions limited in a hundred
dollars per person john sarbanes has a
proposal that would match all three of
these there's the matching fund
component to these there's a tax credit
component to this and there's a pilot
program for vouchers that gets combined
the point is all of these each of them
is focusing on fixing the dynamic of
this corruption by spreading out the
influence more broadly and the
corruption here characterized by a
reality where the per capita influence
of the top one percent is ten times the
per capita influence of the bottom 99
percent combined so my view the
analytics are easy once you see the
problem in the right way the obvious
hard part is the politics and maybe the
impossibly hard part is the politics
because all of the reforms we're talking
about right here would be reforms that
shrink the power of K Street and K
Street of course as Jim Cooper has told
us
is now a Capitol Hill is now a farm
League for K Street you imagine an
emerging business model inside of
Capitol Hill members staffers and
bureaucrats focused on this business
model of their life after government
their life as lobbyists so Public
Citizen calculated between 98 and 2004
50% of the Senate left to become
lobbyists 42% of the house those numbers
I I think I've certainly gone up and as
United Republic calculated last year for
the members they tracked the average
salary increase for those leaving to
become lobbyists as one thousand four
hundred and fifty two percent so if you
have a system where everybody depends
upon the system surviving this is their
retirement package you know when Chris
Murphy was saying it's so terrible these
guys are retiring you know going back to
their districts aren't they really going
back to their districts or are they just
going to K Street and finally cashing in
and making real bucks after paying paid
small amounts of money to be members of
Congress we have a system where
everybody depends upon the system
surviving it's certainly fair to ask how
is it possible to imagine ever giving
them the incentive to change this well
I'm not sure it's possible but I think
there are a couple steps we've got to
take the first step is again to get
clear about what the problem is the
problem is not corporate personhood the
problem is not quote money is speech the
problem is not polarization or
gerrymandering all of these may be
problems not denying we shouldn't find
ways to address all of them but it's not
the problem that defines this corruption
it's not the problem that defines the
particular mechanism which is leading
them to be no longer responsive in the
way the system was designed for them to
be responsive so that's the first step
the second step is to frame this
correctly which means to frame it in a
way that could actually generate a
political movement powerful enough to
win and that means a cross partisan
movement which doesn't I'm not saying it
kind of kumbaya by partisan movement
where we all pretend we love each other
but I mean a movement that cuts across
partisan lines the frames in the soup in
a way that liberals and conservatives
both can genuinely agree that this is
the issue that they want to fight about
and to do this we need a frame
here it is there's a frame they can
somehow bring together people like that
and people like this right two radically
different sorts of people and my view is
the only frame that can do this is one
that focuses again there's United
Republic is nicely done with American
anti-corruption act on corruption
keeping corruption at its core is a way
to talk to different groups so the
different groups identify in this
conversation the part that animates them
and motivates them again the
anti-corruption act does this I think
powerfully and third step this is the
part that I don't think we're gonna have
consensus on or even agreement about and
it just might be false so here we go
the third step is we got to find a way
to act with real consequence here
because memes alone in this fight are
not going to be enough it's not just
about finding the right way to talk
about the problem if you start thinking
about what motivates politicians we have
to recognize what motivates politicians
is fear so we got to talk about what is
the way to bring fear into this equation
so that they can be motivated fear can
motivate them to want to talk about ways
to change the system so there's been an
enormous ly successful movement out
there
groups like Move to Amend leading this
to rally people to get their members of
Congress to propose an amendment to the
Constitution to overturn citizens united
and this movement has succeeded in
getting almost a dozen now states to
pass resolution saying please will you
propose such an amendment thousands of
local districts and other organizations
rallying to suggest this transformation
and last summer 1.9 million signatures
turned in to the Senate asking them to
actually pass this amendment to the
Constitution but this activism is of the
form of a letter to Congress it says
please please
you know cure yourself pretty please
which of course gets filed in the
circular file that exists in most House
and Senate offices right it's not a
strategy of fear it's a strategy
seriousness fear needs to focus on what
can the movement be doing that could
actually produce a consequence that
members of Congress would need to reckon
and begin to react against and here
there is an opportunity in article 5
it's not the ordinary way of amending
the Constitution it's instead Article
fives mechanism for triggering a call
for an article five convention now an
article could 5 convention is not a
constitutional convention constitutional
convention in theory has the power to do
whatever the hell it wants all our
article 5 can convention can do is
follow a procedure for proposing
amendments to the Constitution it's not
a convention that has the power to amend
the Constitution so when people are
fearful of article five conventions what
they have to be fearful of is an idea
coming out of an article five convention
that is really really crazy but still
succeeds in getting three-quarters of
the states to ratify it's okay not
saying it's a zero probability but we
have to understand it's a low
probability now never before have we had
an article five convention we came close
once 1911 I think is the last moment we
came close this was at a time when
Congress had a Senate and the Senate was
selected by legislators state
legislators there's a big movement to
get the Senate to be directly elected
because people thought that was the
source of corruption in that Congress so
in the movement to get them directly
elected they sent letters to Congress
please propose an amendment to change
the way the Senate is selected Congress
ignored that ignored those letters so
the states started proposing an article
v convention for the purpose of changing
the way the Senate was selected and when
they came within one state of having
enough states to force Congress to call
that convention finally Congress flipped
on this issue and sent out the 17th
amendment which it became the amendment
that created an elected Senate and my
reluctant view is that we might have the
same dynamic necessary here that this
convention process
pressures reformed in two ways one just
the expectation that the convention
would be confronted but two in the fact
that these convention movements can be
organized and operate at the local level
it's something for each state to
actually engage in in a way that fuels
the movement of the states and I kind of
think that if you're a member of
Congress and you see this spreading
across the country and this call for
these conventions there's a certain
point at which you recognize the fear
that's appropriate here and that here is
exactly what suggests the way this
problem ultimately could be solvable
okay it is solvable I agree with senator
Murphy it is solvable I also think it
must be solved we don't have a choice
about whether our government is capable
of addressing the most important issues
put aside the less important issues like
copyright term or Internet policy the
most important issues like climate
change or healthcare policy or financial
reform we don't have a choice if we want
to keep the status of this nation as a
leading democracy in the world we don't
have that choice and the only way to get
to the place that we have confidence
again in this government is to remove
what has evolved to be this debilitating
pathological corruption inside the
system a corruption our framers would
have recognized even if our Supreme
Court doesn't yet see okay that's all
I'd like to say I'm happy to take some
questions
and I'm a law professor so I cold call
on people if you don't ask questions hi
professor Lessig Blair Bui with us
purred
I'm wondering why calling for a
convention somehow has more power than
states passing resolutions for the
amendment which are there now 13 states
that have done that why is that gonna be
scarier to Congress than people being
able to move their state legislatures or
pass through ballot initiative a call to
overturn citizens united right so if 34
states pass a resolution that says dear
Congress please propose an amendment to
the Constitution nothing happens no
Congress can ignore it and there is no
legal consequence to them ignoring it
but if 34 states passed a resolution
that says this state calls on Congress
to convene an article five convention
then there has to be an article five
convention and it's the very fact of the
convention which is terrifying to
Congress so my point is each resolution
passed in the States
gets us one step closer to an event
which has legal significance but the
passing of resolutions to get Congress
to pass it and propose an amendment has
no legal consequence now you might say
it could have political consequence but
so too would passing resolutions at the
state level to call on Congress to
propose an article five convention to
have political consequence so it has
political consequence on both sides but
one has legal consequence in addition to
political consequence and that's why I
think it ultimately might be the most
more effective and the other thing is
you know let's say you've got five
states to pass it very quickly
then you'd have a whole bunch of people
that begin to say well this is kind of a
fun thing let's see how we can get more
states to pass these revolutions and as
you got closer there'd be even more
excitement and energy driven to this
movement to try to get these states to
pass these resolutions in a way that I
think with resolution response that
we've seen right now as Congress does
nothing it kind of dampens
the enthusiasm down for actually getting
more states to pass these resolutions so
let me be very clear I didn't say this
clearly enough here I think the movement
to get the states to pass resolutions
has been the most important thing in the
past four years in making this issue
salient and important to Americans I
would not have given up that movement
for anything so it's not but because
only because that movement has succeeded
in getting millions of people focused on
this issue in a way that gives them a
taste for something actually happening
so that was a wonderful amazingly
powerful brilliant first step wasn't my
idea of a first step I thought we should
have done something different so I'm
speaking against interest when I say it
was the brilliant first step but I think
we need to recognize it was just a first
step and now the question is what do we
do to move them to the next step that
gets us closer to having the political
power necessary to bring about the kind
of change that that will have to have a
political science department so there's
sort of in congruence between how you
described a lot of what motivates donors
and also the same thing with the last
panel between how I see it which is I
spent a lot of time at these high-dollar
fundraisers and in the call center at
the d-triple-c and it seems to me that
most of these big donors the 0.1 or
whatever percent are hobbyists rather
than lobbyists they are people they're
not idle and they're not asking for
anything they they want to be called by
a politician because politicians are
celebrities and they want to go to
cocktail parties and mingle with other
rich people and talk about politics
because for most people politics is no
more than a hobby and when I think about
these big dollar donors I think not all
of them are like that but maybe the most
them are most the ones certainly who
attend these different fundraising
events are and the reason I bring that
up because I wonder whether this is the
population that needs to be co-opted
whether they don't actually care about
getting things they just care about
being involved in politics and and in
settings like this when we talk about
money in politics they're often treated
as a this kind of the bad guys and I
wonder if that's the wrong
framing and strategic approach so first
I do agree it's wrong
to think of them as the bad guys and you
know I also think it's wrong for
reformers to somehow think that they are
not proper reformers if they play the
game the way everybody else plays the
game I think Chris Murphy today was
absolutely right when he responded the
question about you know what do you what
do you think I think was your question
what do you think when the big money is
on your side with look you know I've got
to get into office and do what I can
when I'm in office and this I'm happy
for the support that this gives me and I
think so long as they've committed
themselves firmly to reforming the
system they're innocent in this respect
you know because the people who say I'm
not taking any big money I'm only gonna
take five dollars for each contributions
they are not people sitting in Congress
right they lose and so you might be
right
I don't think you know these are
necessarily bad people there are a lot
of them motivated for the best possible
reasons to be inside of politics but
again an issue that came up in the first
panel I think it's absolutely powerful
and right we have to think about the
effect on the margin so even if 90% of
those people are in it just because they
want the photo-op what that means is the
candidate doesn't care about what those
90 percent think about but the candidate
even more than focused on what the
marginal 10% think about right so you
think about political parties in you
know like Israel where the where the
smallest party might have the most power
in determining what in fact the
Parliament does that's the similar point
that goes on here so if what you're
saying is true it only exacerbates the
sense in which it's the tiniest fraction
of the population that is driving or
creating the kind of dependency that I'm
talking about and so it doesn't change
the ultimate policy prescription which
is we have to find a way to spread that
influence out you know now over the size
of all those funders but now not just
over the funders but over everybody as
well thanks so much for this
presentation just just to maybe push
that point a little bit further when I
think about what's influencing elected
officials you know Chris Murphy this
morning talked about going to these
cocktail parties in DC where there's
this highly stable community of special
interest representatives you know both
in from
our mental groups as well as from the
you know chemical industry whatever and
that that's not going to change if we
reform how money is used in elections
the the stable discursive community and
your your attention to the the level
which corruption works the level of
institutions I think is really important
but I think there's an even higher level
and maybe corruptions out the word in
which the discursive communities in
which these politicians are spending
their time just are highly wedded to the
the sort of status quo and really deep
sense and I'm not sure that getting
money out of politics is gonna address
that you know even deeper level of
influence okay so first of all let's be
clear about language I don't want to get
money out of politics I want money in
politics I'm gonna change the way we
fund raise that money if we change the
way we fund raise that money the economy
of lobbying changes dramatically right
it's not the case that we get rid of
lobbyists and we shouldn't get rid of
obvious lobbyists are essential they're
really critical to help Congress
understand how Congress is about to
screw up some new industry right so so
I'm not against that information being
there but the dependence that members
have on the favor of the lobbyists has
been changed dramatically because no
longer is the member looking for the
lobbyist to in some subtle and legal way
channel the money to the campaign of
that member that that member needs now
the lobbyists just just one more person
pleading with the member for the members
attention and what that does is not you
know disable them but it changes the way
in which they are super enabled given
the way we fund the system you know as
John Edwards used to say when we used to
quote John Edwards there's all the
difference in the world between a lawyer
making an argument to a jury and a
lawyer handing out hundred-dollar bills
to the jurors but our lobbying system
doesn't understand that difference and
so if you made that as a difference they
would be in the business of making
arguments now if they were just in the
business of making arguments I would
predict members of Congress would not
spend as much time as they do going to
their stupid parties you know because
they are just not fun it is just not a
fun way to live their life Sartre
sarbanes describes how in his first six
years in Congress he had lunch with a
colleague six times any colleague six
times over those six years and the
answer was well you know if you have
time for
you have time to fundraise or to go to a
fundraiser and who would go who would
have lunch with somebody if you could go
to a fundraiser or be fundraising but
the point is if you've got to a world
but that's not the way they fund raised
if instead it was fund raising through
the ways you would expect $50.00
contributions to be raised they would
have more time to do the sort of thing
they used to do not back in the 19th
century you know we're talking about
getting back to a world of 1970s in the
1980s it's not a radical difference that
we're talking about it's just a
difference sufficient enough to get us
back to a Congress like you could
actually do something could actually
legislate because it didn't have these
forces you know the way Chris Murphy
today was just brilliant they're just
prescribing the way from the very first
moment you're speaking in a way that
makes it feel like a sin to sit down
with somebody on the other side and talk
to that person so this is polarization
in the way that era is very focused on
it but the point is to recognize the way
in which the fundraising is helping to
drive the polarization so take that all
away we are still left with a political
Society which is demographically more
polarized than it was in 1970 no doubt
but at least you know we're doing about
we're doing something about the thing we
can do something about constitutionally
like you could imagine we could
lobotomize half of the American public
and that would deal with polarization
too but that's just not constitutionally
permissible to lobotomize the American
public so let's do the thing we can do
something about which is to change the
way we fund elections okay great
in New York University um first of all I
found your talk really interesting is I
thought the idea of institutionally
putting fear in the minds of members of
Congress really inspired but I'm also
sort of nervous that we're a head of the
public or everybody in this room is a
head of the public because that idea of
putting fear and members of Congress is
based on members of the public going
along with this and to the extent that
going along with this means at the end
of the day they're gonna support some
sort of matching funds I think that's
really tough at the moment because if
you look at what what I've seen in
public opinion on this people just
freaked out as soon as you say give
money to politicians and so I'm sort of
nervous that we're way ahead of what is
palatable politically at the moment so
cute
first I'd suggest that in fact the data
is much more complicated than that makes
it seem I'm pretty confident we have the
support in the public for the ideas
here's where the problem is
klaris did a poll last summer where they
found that 80% of Americans believe
every single reform Congress has ever
passed it has passed for the purpose of
benefiting it and disabling competitors
so if a member of Congress stands up and
says I've got a great new idea it's
called matching funds it's going to make
it so we have competitive elections 80%
of Americans will discount that and
think the reason you're saying this is
you're just trying to benefit yourself
and this points to a really fundamental
problem we as a political society have
about even imagining what the solution
here would be I testified at the Senate
last July and talked about you know in
citizens united and the question was you
know what they should do for an
amendment to address citizens I said
look your biggest problem is not coming
up with the amendment that's pretty
easier the biggest problem is coming up
of the amendment that the American
public would believe is actually of us a
solution to the problem and it's not
just that Congress can't give us that
answer there is no institution in
American society the Americans trust
right now the law professors they would
not trust the church they would not
trust the ACLU they would not trust you
know you tell me the organization that a
cross partisan group of Americans would
actually trust here
so I agree with you we have an enormous
ly difficult task to produce an idea in
a way that America would buy but I also
think that the data that comes from
people like tipping's and I'm sorry
hitting's and T's Morris suggests that
the Americans Americans are deeply
focused on these process issues and are
desperate for a kind of reform that
gives them a reason to believe that
Congress is just not playing an
insider's game for the benefit of the
insiders I wonder if you could talk
about the your the part where you were
talking about fear and members of
Congress and that part of this is
getting them to a point where they feel
safe passing small donor a small donor
system but what I'm hearing out of
Albany right now we're just such a
system is being
host is that what is the most creating
the most fear is independent
expenditures so in the small donor model
how do you think about dealing with that
part of the problem which may be a
barrier to passing the right so I said
we could take the first step in solving
this problem without addressing the
constitutional issue and the more
expanded answer to that is it may be
that we then need to address the
constitutional issue but I think there
are a couple reasons to recognize why we
might not need to address a
constitutional issue one very hopeful
reason is the Supreme Court will find a
way to back off from the extremism a
civil United and the Arizona free
enterprise case and I think it's
possible for them to back off I think
it's possible for Kennedy to save face
and back off from the more extreme
version of that especially if they
understood you know the kind of
dependence corruption originalism point
that I'm making right here gives them a
way to talk about corruption which is
not we were wrong in Citizens United we
were right in Citizens United
Citizens United the nonprofit filmmaker
of course ought to have the right to
spend its corporate funds to promote its
film that's nothing to do with
corruption under any sense of corruption
but that's separate from the question
whether people should be able to
contribute unlimited amounts of money to
an independent political action
committee to spend in a an election
that's a different issue and so I think
jurisprudentially there's a way for them
to actually back off from citizens
united consistent with what they did in
citizens united or back off from the
implications united but even if it's not
likely that they will do this it's a
very old court in ten years you know the
key people here are two of the key
people here will no longer be on that
court right so the idea of us building a
progressive movement to take on a
decision of the Supreme Court which in
ten years will disappear anyway just
seems to me like a wrong waste of our
resources we've got to be focusing our
resources on a political movement that
would actually address the thing that we
really have the hard work to do which is
to convince the American people we have
to change the way we fund elections that
is the necessary change
and it might be the sufficient change
but it certainly is the necessary change
if we're ever going to get to a system
of elections that we have a reason to
trust I'd be interested in hearing your
thoughts on two alternative sources of
political resistance to these reforms
one being a sort of bipartisan
resistance based on the advantages that
the current system has for all members
of Congress which you've written very
compellingly on and the other is a sort
of partisan resistance where if the
reforms become cast or framed in a way
that they're perceived as advantaging
one cardi versus the other then not only
will that create huge resistance among
you know enough people to veto those
reforms but also allow them to then cast
those reforms in a way that will
undermine their support among roughly
half of the public right right both
questions I think point to the same
answer and it's a really hard answer for
us post twentieth-century people to
accept so the twentieth century model of
big social movements that succeed gets
captured by the kind of civil rights
movement which for us is captured by the
idea of like one or two really important
leaders who define the movement and we
have big organizations supporting the
movement and it finally takes on the
great power of whatever and wins that's
not the way this movement can work this
movement has to look a lot more like the
progressive movement at the beginning of
the last century the progressive
movement beginning of last century
didn't have television or even radio
right they didn't have a single
organization that defined the
progressives there were progressives
from every single sector there were
conservative progressives Alaia and
there were liberal progressives you know
in the Democratic and Republican Party
there were progressives of every sort
and they spoke to the progressively
relevant issue of their own group right
but what made them progressives was the
recognition that the political system
was no longer delivering the promise of
a democracy which is a connection
between what the people wanted and what
the government actually did and so they
fought on their own little
but could could resonate on the bigger
issue that we have some big some big
case to take on and in 1912 remember we
have four candidates for president in
1912 a socialist Debs is stan pat
republican taft
and two self-described quote
progressives one Teddy Roosevelt and
Woodrow Wilson
but the progressivism of Roosevelt and
Wilson are very different progressivism
right in between the two progressives
seventy percent of the American public
vote for a progressive which points to
the fundamental recognition even though
there's significant divergence here now
what that means for us today I think is
that we need to find a way to build a
movement there's one outside the beltway
so it's not Democrats and Republicans
inside Washington that are lead
champions they are going to be important
ultimately to passing the legislation
but they are not important in building
the movement and to that constantly
recognizes the critical importance to
keeping conservatives as prominent as
liberals so I get Josh silver is here he
runs well United Republic I mean not a
Republican in my Republic and represent
us but what represent us has been doing
is working extremely hard to promote
very strong conservatives and we had a
conference on route strikers conference
in San Francisco where the guy who was
the former bush ethics our guy named
Richard painter was on the stage and he
advanced the most radical voucher like
solution
Bruce Ackerman's idea of all of them he
wanted $200 voucher to everybody he said
this is a taxation without
representation points like everyone of
us ought to be represented in the
funding and I should not have to pay any
taxes until I have $200 in a voucher
amount and that's exactly the kind of
rhetoric and positioning that I think is
going to be necessary to balance the
general perception that it's a bunch of
Liberal Democrats who are pushing this
idea so you know people say to me can't
you now get Barack Obama to take up this
issue and in my heart of hearts the
answer is I don't want him to take up
this issue it's exact would be it would
be poison for him right now to take up
this issue I don't think he has the
constitutional standing to bring about
the change anyway even if I thought he
did then maybe it would be different but
he does but the point is if he did take
this up as the big issue then you're
right it would be framed as a Democrats
issue and and there's no way to make
fundamental reform here without having
cross partisan support as hard as it is
for me the Democrat to admit only Nixon
goes to China it might be that the real
hope we have is if some credible
Republican sort of finally recognizes
why this is a total win-win for them to
take this up as the core anti crony
capitalism issue that most about
grassroots Republicans care about I was
just curious what you make of these the
other line of efforts short of
constitutional amendment that you've got
going on now on the corporate side just
the shareholder movement the what the
SEC is talking about now this this
proposal to go through state corporate
law its revised state corporate law to
make it tougher and I know business
spending is only one part of this but
what do you make of that whole line of
so I guess my view is I'm not against it
but I don't want a lot of resources
devoted to it because you know III sure
Michael's view that I don't really think
that corporate money is the issue you
know from that I mean we have a good
point it's made by the transparency
people that we don't actually know how
much corporate money was in this
election because of the secret money was
there but the money that we do know it's
11 percent of the super PAC money and so
solve that problem if super citizen
United had gone completely the other way
and embolden the FEC to stamp out all
corporate influence we still would have
a way of funding the election where the
tiniest fraction of the 1% was funding
the election so I of course I'm for
transparency of course and for corporate
responsibility of course I'm for all of
these reforms they're all great but if
we need to get all of them
we are still nowhere closer to
addressing the core problem here which
is this kind of corruption so you know
happy that they're doing it but please
don't waste your time well on that note
we're not going to waste our time we're
going to continue on we're gonna head
downstairs for the I guess the third
half of our program to use the car tech
phrasing and I will just say what
I've said many times before that Pam
green will be standing out there on your
way down if you if you want to talk
about your travel you have any questions
about the rest of the day you should
talk with her and I think we should all
give a very warm round of applause to to
Larry Lessig